good afternoon everybody
welcome to this simultaneous meeting of
baba district
council cabinet yes okay district
council cabinet
i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
district council cabinet please remember
to use the chat first
that you wish to speak and not to post
comments or questions
and please note the messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i will now ask the government's office
officer to carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members from baber and mid
suffolk we also have the following
councillors attending the meeting
councillor lavinia hadingham councillor
rachel ebern
councillor john field councillor
alastair mccraw
and councillor keith wellam we also have
the following officers in attendance
chief executive deputy monitoring
officer
the assistant director for customer
services assistant director for housing
corporate manager for finance and
commissioning procurement
and professional lead for kitty sites
and infrastructure thank you
thank you can i move to the agenda
please item one
apologies for absence i will now ask the
governance officer to roll call for the
members present
thank you chair if you could indicate
your presence when i call your name
baby district council members councillor
clive alfie
present councillor dave busby
president councillor derrick davis i
don't believe we have in attendance
councillor michael holt present
councillor elizabeth malvezi present
councillor jan osborne present councilor
lee parker
present councillor john ward
president thank you and for mid-suffolk
councillor gerard brewster
present councillor david byrne president
councillor julie flatman present
council jessica fleming present council
of peace of gould
present councillor susie morley
present councillor harry richardson
present and councillor john whitehead
present
thank you chair
thank you item two to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
item three mca 19
67 confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the
mid-suffolk cabinet meeting held on the
6th of july
2020 at 11 30 a.m
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
thank you could i have a proposal please
uh yes chair happy to propose councillor
julie flatman
thank you councillor flatman and a
second please uh john whitehead happy
2nd
thank you councillor whitehood the
governance officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair i'm going to hand over
to mandy who will talk you through the
instructions for carrying out the vote
okay um so counsellors if you can
in your modern.gov app if you can go
to the plus sign
and then into the voting option
there should be an in-progress vote
no
oh hold on have you started it claire
yes i have now sorry so there should be
a blue line
for the vote that is in progress
if you click on that blue line you
should get your voting options
i'm just gonna start
can you see how many votes you're
waiting for thank you we've just got
seven votes
chair can i ask for your vote please
i vote for thank you thank you so that
is
unanimous chair eight votes for
lovely thank you i'm now going to hand
over to councillor ward
for the baby cabinet meeting
thank you right um the the baby
frozen on me
yeah uh paper bca 1958
the minutes of the baba cabinet meeting
held on the 6th of july
at 9 00 a.m you'll find these on pages 7
to 12 of your agenda pack
um is everyone happy for uh accuracy
and uh content please if there are no
questions
may i have a proposal
i'll propose john if you want to it's
clivarthy
thank you and uh i'll
hand over then for the electronic vote
okay thank you chair so again if um
if faber members
can select the vote which should show is
in progress
hmm
okay we have received all those votes
can i ask councillor halt
please as well yes i approve
thank you so that's seven out of seven
four chair so that's unanimous
thank you thank you moving on to
item 4 mca 19-68
the confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid-suffolk cabinet
meeting
held on the 6th of july at 2 30.
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
thank you can i have a proposal please
um councillor jessica fleming i'm happy
to propose these minutes as accurate
thank you councillor fleming and a
seconder please
happy to second madam chair thank you
councillor brewster
uh the governance officer will now
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair if you can now cast your
votes please
thank you chair can i ask for your vote
please
uh vote for thank you thank you so that
again is unanimous eight votes for
thank you very much and i'll now hand
over to council award for the
cabinet obama cabinet minutes
thank you um right that's uh paper bca
1959
the minutes of the cabinet meeting we
held on the 6th of july
at 2 30 p.m are there any
uh comments regarding accuracy or
content
please from anyone if
not may i have a proposal please
i'm happy to approve john yeah thank you
thank you council halt
thank you and uh okay then
um can we conduct the electronic vote
now please
thank you chair yes councillors if you
could cast your votes now
still showing has not started okay
i don't know where i am
okay mandy is the vote in progress
hello mandy
maddie's on hold okay
yeah it's certainly not started
according to
my screen here yeah okay i think for
this
we'll if you're happy chair i'll do this
bar roll call
yes thank you thank you okay so if when
i call your names if you could
indicate four against or abstain
councillor clive alfie
four councillor dave busby
paul councillor michael holt
or councillor elizabeth malvisi
councillor john osborne four
councillor lee parker four and
councillor john ward
four thank you chair that's unanimous
again
thank you so the minutes of the meeting
have been meetings
have been confirmed and will be signed
at the next practicable
opportunity now moving on to item five
to receive notifications of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
non-received chair thank you
item six questions by councillors
non-received chair thank you item seven
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees
there were none thank you
item 8 forthcoming decisions list does
anybody have any comments
no thank you very much so
item nine mca
19 69 and bca
19 60 are the general fund financial
monitoring reports for
2020 21 quarter one
so i'll now invite the mid-suffolk
cabinet member for economy
to introduce the mid-suffolk district
council report
uh thank you madam chairman um in my
finance capacity
i will introduce the report um being
general fund financial monitoring for
quarter one
uh which starts on page 15 of today's
mid suffolk pack
this is an important report as its first
time that we've set out in a public
record
our best estimates of the impact of
kovid 19
on the council's finances section 5
which is headed financial impacts of
kovid 19
contains three pages of detailed
narrative explain the additional costs
we've incurred
the income reduction suffered the impact
on council tax and business rates
the financial support we've had from
central government and the medium term
implications now many figures within the
report
can only be best estimates based on
present knowledge
and careful considered assumptions about
the balance of the year
but gradually the impacts on our council
finances
and the challenges arising and becoming
clearer
council income variances against budget
having previous years
usually been positive often quite
significantly
so the forecast for 2021 comes quite a
shock
in the first quarter alone we've seen a
700 000
adverse effect and we anticipate for the
full year
a 2.4 million pound effect and that's
based on income starting to recover
and with no further lockdown a section
5.4
bleakly states if things don't recover
as quickly as hoped
then the situation will be far worse
the additional costs incurred have been
outlined in section 5.1
there's been various transits of
financial support from central
government
as detailed in section 5.8 totaling 1.34
million
and further support has recently been
announced for sales fees and charges
and this is in the process of being
evaluated
the report sets out the reasons why the
impact of business rates and council tax
will hit us
in 2021 and beyond rather than this year
due to the way the collection fund works
with its built-up reserve
acting as a short-term buffer it's clear
even at this stage
the budget process for 2021 including
the four-year medium-term
outlook will be a particularly
challenging exercise
code 19's impact on this year's outturn
network government support
may be around 1.9 million
where there are several budget savings
identified and other items that lead to
an unfunded gap
of 970 000 the council has a strong
reserve position
some reserves being the general
contingency nature and some
specifically earmarked the section 151
officer is confident
that these reserves are sufficient to
manage the impact on 2021
and i concur with this view there are of
course many other day-to-day variances
arising
and these are set out in the table in
section 6.7
one notable one is the staff vacancy
management which currently anticipates
to be
592 000 positive
taking everything into account the
overall deficit position
subject further budget variances is
expected to be a hundred and one
thousand pounds
as i said at the start of this
introduction the financial position is
merely for noting at this stage
our capital spending program has been
delayed as a result of covered 19
and appendix d has the details it's
impossible to overstate the amount of
thought effort analysis
that our finance team have put into
evaluating our financial position
in these unprecedented times and i'd
like to acknowledge this and thank them
so madam chairman it just remains for me
to move the recommendations set out in
section three
and to ask for a second thank you
you have a second um chair uh i would
very much like to
um second the this report
and its recommendations i i think it's a
reflection of the
fundamental competence of this
administration
when it comes to finance and as
the portfolio holder said the uh
quality and dedication of our finance
team that
we have the options that we do have
in terms of managing the pressures
which were severe that arising from
covid
and i think it's a testament to the
wisdom of the approach taken
in terms of building up the level of
reserves that we have
that we're able certainly to manage the
position
in the current financial year
albeit uh we face as as uh
councillor has said we face some real
challenges
uh in the years ahead thank you very
much so i'd like to second the report
thank you very much councillor gould and
i now
hand over to council award for the baber
report thank you cousin morley
and i'd like to introduce paper bca
1960 which is the general fund financial
monitoring for the first quarter
of the current financial year for baba
so i'm pleased to present report bca
1960 to cabinet
the general fund quarter one financial
monitoring covering the revenue and
capital financing performance for the
period april to june 2020
this is our first look at how we think
our general fund is shaping up for the
full year
compared to the budget and this year of
course incorporates the impact of code
19 on the council's finances
as you are all aware the challenges
presented by the covenant 19 outbreak
have resulted in significant unplanned
costs and loss of income
however this is a changing position and
the information presented here will
change during the year
taking this into consideration i am
pleased to report that the position for
the council is positive
at this early stage in the year we are
anticipating a surplus of 62 000 pounds
compared with budget
and this is net of favorable and adverse
variances in the cost centers and income
streams
the key variances for the of the full
year forecast compared with budget are
set out in paragraph 6.7 the main
adverse variances are
an additional curve at expenditure of
923 000 pounds
um there's a risk to the business rates
pooling benefit due to covered 19 of 323
000 pounds
and we've got income lost from a number
of uh revenue streams planning 251
000 pounds waste 231 000 pounds
building control 106 000 pounds car
parks yep car park income
down 88 000 pounds and licensing 70 000
pounds
there's also an adverse variance of 103
000 pounds on cifco
and other commercial investments of 175
000 pounds
but these are offset by under spends an
additional income
uh from a number of sources we've had
received
additional funding including monies from
central government to support kevin 19
of 1.66 million pounds
and uh we've got a positive vacant
vacancy management saving of 592 000
pounds
the financial impact of kerbin 19 the
additional costs income reduction
impact on council tax and business rates
offset by the financial support
report we have received to date is
presented in section 5 of the report
the total income loss is currently 2.2
million but this does include cifco
which is not in the overall position uh
in terms of our
our 62 000 power surplus as we will
accrue for any shortfall at the end of
the year
as described in paragraph 5.9 we are
still awaiting additional support for
irrecoverable sales fees and charges
income
which will improve our position however
the total impact of coven 19 is
currently 3.1 million pounds and
government support only covers less than
half of this
leaving us to fund the remainder budget
savings will help here but there is
still at the present time
an unfunded gap of 640 000 pounds which
will have to be funded from reserves
as i said earlier this figure will
undoubtedly change as the year
progresses
the median term position presented in
paragraphs 5.13 to 5.
15 is unfortunately more worrying and
shows an increasing deficit
from 1.1 million pounds to 2.3 million
pounds over the three years to 2023-24
further savings will need to be
identified and a comprehensive budget
challenge commenced
last month however unfortunately the
impact of curving 19 is likely to be
felt for many years to come
paragraph 6.11 of the report summarizes
the current predicted movements in the
transformation fund with a forecast
balance of 880
000 pounds at the end of the year at
this stage we're
not showing a transfer of any of the 62
000 pound surplus to this
as it is likely along with other reserve
movements to change
the transformation fund details have
provided independent speeding
the payments say shows how we're
spending the business rates pilot
eight hundred and twelve thousand pounds
of this is still unspent of which two
hundred and eighty
thousand pounds is as yet unallocated
and appendix c sets out our general fund
earmarked reserves including forecast
transfers
these reserves may steady remain steady
at around 5.2 million pounds
excluding uh sill and paragraph 6.12 to
6.16 provide more detail on specific
movements
our general fund capital program is
detailed independence d
and paragraph 617-620 this is currently
forecasting a significant underspend of
21.7 million pounds
several projects have been delayed as a
result of curving 19 including the
further investment at cifco
which is now expected to be fully
invested towards the end of next year
work is underway on the joint asset
management strategy and this will set
out plans to utilize
the strategic investment fund therefore
any spends will be carried forward
2021-2022
finally i'd like to thank our finance
team for all their hard work and
tracking the progress against budget in
a rapidly changing situation
as well as preparing the regular returns
to government
before opening up for questions and
debate i'd first like to move the
recommendations in section 3
of the report let the surplus of 62 000
pounds be noted and that the capital
program be noted
may i have a second for these
recommendations please
thank you councillor osborne so
i'm now going to look for questions from
both mid-suffolk and
baber cabinets if anybody would like to
indicate by raising their hand in the
in in the chamber
no questions okay thank you
so um questions from any other members
present
uh councillor eben you have a question
[Music]
um thank you very much um chair um i've
got um
several questions if i may so i'll be as
brief as i can
but i'd also like to echo councillor
whitehead's
remarks um to thank the um finance staff
particularly
for their work because it is a very sort
of fast-changing
um arena at the moment with um different
government
grants and so forth so so my thanks to
them as well
um just with regards to the grants that
we
do receive from government um we're
expecting at some point
this grant that will cover um
75 of losses beyond five percent of
planned income
um do we have any indication of when um
that might be or when or when we would
expect to hear from government
um and on this on a similar note um with
regards to car park income
in mid-suffolk the report refers to
a loss there
of 160 on
sorry on 6.7 paragraph 6.7
and that's in relation to what we'd have
expected for the whole year of 661 000
pounds in income
income and i just wondered um if that
loss is for the whole year and whether
we're expecting that
um to change and very briefly
on paragraph 6.11 we've it refers to
829 000 pounds um
spend towards the former council
headquarters
and i wanted an explanation on that if i
may and finally
the disabled facilities grant i note the
underspend
and i've of 910 000 pounds and i know
that we are looking
um to move to to improve that future but
i just wondered when we would see
options to improve this
thank you very much chair much
appreciate being able to ask
these questions thank you thank you
thank you councillor eben uh councillor
whitehead do you or
your officer team uh wish to reply to
that
well yes i'll make a start anyway um the
um
the grant foreseeable from the
government to cover this loss of
income on the various lines is obviously
going to be very
welcome received um my understanding at
the moment is that we'll be doing
three returns over the rest of the year
once at the end of um
september well within september to cover
the period april to july
and that payment should come through in
october then one
for through to in december the period
august november
paint in january and then finally one
for the for the balance of the year
um which would expect to get in may 2021
so as we say the first five percent
against budget
we're going to take the hit ourselves
and then the
government are saying that we'll pay for
75
of the um loss beyond that
and at the moment we anticipate that
could be in the region of 790 000
pounds and i think events yeah in terms
of the the cash
for cash flow when that will be coming
in
uh second question i noted uh about the
car park income 361
000 well that is the best estimate
at this point in time so i'm just trying
to find it again
obviously we had the issue with the
machines back in april and may be
enclosed covered
and going forward the 361 is a full year
best estimate but obviously or anything
could change between
now and the end of the year including
lockdowns or whatever
but that's our best estimate at the
moment for a full year figure
hq spend extra let me just
find that within the report um
i believe that'll be to do with um
mainly
security type aspects but if a
officer can just confirm that more
details
john that was paragraph 6.11.
it hadn't been in the previous um
reports
that's six point eleven
in the table oh yeah yes
um well i think that's coming from the
growth efficiency fund so that will
i assume big costs um to progress the
um the progress of various build outs
you know on our
programmer build on that site which is
mainly i believe
market rent of sorry market to
sales properties but um if one of the
members of the officers could just
confirm that
i'm not thank you thank you uh
councillor whitehead yep
um the officers were just conferring on
that one
um we think uh well i think it might be
a contribution to capital
towards the you know the works that are
being done at the hq
site uh but i think we will need to just
confirm that one outside of
the meeting and let everybody know thank
you very much
thank you and just the last one was just
on the um
disabled facilities grant and and
whether we um
we potentially see some options on that
one thank you very much
yes um disabled facilities grants
um which page was that honorary that was
uh paragraph 620
620 thank you thank you i was looking at
the appendix
um 6 20.
yes it says options are currently being
considered on expiry of the current
contract arrangements
which is due to expire at the end of
november some anticipation is
we'll be bringing that forward fairly
soon but again if obstacles could just
confirm
if there's any date known at this time
gavin would you like to respond
yes thank you chair uh good afternoon
everybody so just in relation to
uh dfg's we are actually bringing a
report to
cabinet next month um in respect to the
ending of the current orbit hia contract
and our proposals to bring that service
in-house
that is a paper that will also be
considered by the joint overview and
scrutiny committee
uh at their next meeting as well so the
the replacement for the existing service
will take effect from november this year
and officers have been uh busily working
on that over the past three months
thank you very much for that thank you
thank you thank you everybody
councillor field
no you've muted yourself
the benefit is you can't hear yourself
swear when you do that
just uh just looking at page 23 i think
rachel's got
most of the questions i would have
wanted but um
looking at the vacancy management factor
so let's quote it on 23.
uh first of all that is for mid-suffolk
is it because i i
i thought i heard um councillor ward
mentioned 592 grand for baber
and it sounds like the same number but
the real question there is
it is in two ways uh it's that seems
quite a large number
it suggests we're quite way you know um
10 people plus below budget
so my question in a way is um
twofold one if that is a large number
then
sort of what work are we not getting
done because we have that number of
people
uh not in the establishment and the
alternative
way of looking at that perhaps is uh
if we don't actually need them why are
they in the budget in the first place
thank you who would like to have a go at
that
um arthur yeah put my hand up thank you
chairman
um yes you're absolutely right we're
constantly looking at our staffing
complement counselor field to make sure
that we've got
the right resources to match the the
needs that that all councillors
would expect us to deliver obviously the
coveted situation has a significant
impact
and that's not to say we haven't been
doing any recruitment uh during
the pandemic period we have had some
virtual recruitment uh and i think
kevin fisk is appointing or rather
recruiting later i think in the next
couple of weeks
for a key post for example in terms of
building services manager
and that's a virtual recruitment
exercise so we have been able to do some
recruitment during this period but of
course it's different and so we've not
been able to recruit in the normal way
and so we have had
slightly more vacancies than we normally
would have held you're right in terms of
roughly the kind of numbers
you were talking about because that
needs to be put against an overall
staffing complement
of over 500 people so we're still
talking about a relatively
low number in terms of an overall
vacancy percentage
as it were but it's something we will
constantly keep under a review
i'm sure like all counselors you would
like us to have the right number of
staff
not too many not too few to make sure
that we
can deliver what you would want us to
achieve
thank you very much can i just uh could
i just
sorry john could i just uh check the
thing what is it we're not delivering
course of those vacancies or are they
distributed so it's not
identifiable so they're certainly
sitting here today in front of you i i
couldn't give you a definitive in terms
of where each of those vacancies sit but
they are distributed is not one service
area in that regard
it's equally not one vacancy that's been
sitting vacant throughout
so it will be a combination of a post
for example that's vacant
then filled different posts becomes
vacant and then be filled again so it's
not
uh simply to use your your example 10
posts that have sat
vacant throughout the period of time but
if if members would like more detail on
that we can certainly
uh provide that in terms of where those
vacancies are certainly the one that i
can certainly easily talk about
is my um other strategic director as you
appreciate jonathan stevenson left just
before christmas
and that was a decision that we're going
to go out to recruitment uh around about
march ironically
um and i've made the decision to be
inappropriate uh to do so in the
meantime
and we may well and i'll need to give
some consideration as to whether it
becomes appropriate
but that's a decision for further on
down the line
thank you thank you john whitehead did
you want to carry on
well just to to the point in terms of
the the figure quoted
from mississippi and the figure quoted
for baber is an identical figure
but that's basically because the total
saving is split
literally 50 50 is how we do split staff
costs
okay thank you thank you very much
councilman mcgraw
thank you chair
now you've muted yourself again
there we go i think that's working now
my apologies counselor morning
um i just uh we had some figures from
councillor whitehead regarding the
government grants
uh that might address a shortfall um for
babe
for mid-suffolk i wonder if we could
have similar figures for baba from uh
council award or an officer
right yes which page are you looking at
councillor mccraw
uh well actually i'm just referring to
the figures that were supplied in
response to councillor ebern's question
regarding uh government grants that
might address the shortfall
with us absorbing the first five percent
then there was a mention of 75 percent
now i make that 80
so i'm wondering what's happened to the
other 20
um um or if i missed something
right um well the equivalent figure for
baber is that
we are expecting 557 000 pounds to be
covered by the government
um so the way it's calculated that the
first five percent
um of income is is taken out of the
equation
and then we look at the losses on the
rest and take 75
percent of that um which is where uh
what the government will cover us for
so in total the estimate at the moment
for baby is as i said 557 000 pounds
so a fairly limited form of insurance
yeah but um quite a good one um to be
honest
um it's uh it's certainly a better
position than we could have expected uh
uh some months ago so um but i
would have to say that it doesn't cover
commercial income losses
but then um the
the way we're looking at cifco at the
moment is is that uh a lot of those um
well a lot of the reduction in cifco
income will will be deferred rather than
lost so um uh it does make sense for
the commercial income uh to be excluded
from this picture
okay thank you councilwood somewhat
similar to
an excess yeah yes oh very much so
yeah uh councillor field you've still
got your hand
up would you like to take it down or
have you got another question
i'll take it down thank you arthur have
you got a question
no apologies just hadn't taken a hand
down okay
councillor mccraw have you got another
question
on the assumption that's uh no more
questions from councilman crore i'm now
going to
open up the item for debate
so would you like to indicate by raising
your hands if you would
like to speak
no okay thank you
i will now ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you
hello are there any governance officers
available to start the vote
apologies chair i was on mute i was
i was happily chatting away okay let me
just start that vote for you
so your vote should now show in progress
so if you could
cast your votes sorry one moment
right hold on one moment for me i'm
gonna start that again
okay so mid suffolk members your vote
should now be in progress if you could
cast your votes
okay we're waiting for one more vote to
come in
um i don't seem to have the um
line item to vote on i'm sorry
chancellor fleming
okay i suggest then we take
your vote and councillor morley's vote
as a verbal vote if that's
okay with you chair yeah okay so if i
can ask
councillor fleming for against or
abstain four
okay thank you and councillor morley
before thank you
thank you so that's eight votes for
chair that's unanimous thank you
lovely thank you and if you could
yeah we'll now go over to baber
so when the blue line shows is in
progress if i could ask you to place
your
votes
um
um
okay we're still waiting for one member
madam chairman that might be me it's
councillor general's born my blue line
hasn't come up to enabling me to vote
okay it may be um can you see the item
on there can you actually see
oh you can okay again then i will take
your vote councillor osborne
verbally so um
if i go alphabetically council a halt
for against her abstain please
or
thank you
so that's unanimous chair seven votes
for thank you
thank you very much moving on to
item 10 this is mca 19
70 and bca 19
61 the housing revenue account financial
monitoring report
for quarter one for twenty twenty slash
twenty twenty one
i will now invite the mid suffer cabinet
member for economy to introduce the mid
suffer
sorry not i apologize
cabinet member for finance to introduce
the mid-suffolk district council report
thank you madam chairman yeah i'd like
to make a brief introduction to report
mca 1970 which is the housing revenue
account
financial monitoring for quarter one
again
as for the general fund report this
report includes assessing the impact of
kobit 19
on the council's finances as always with
the hra
the short-term outlook should also be
reviewed in the context of a rolling
30-year business plan
the budgeted in-ear deficit of 564 000
is currently expected to more than
double to 1.159 million
now the line-by-line details which are
driving this increase
are set out in table in paragraph 6.3
supported by the narrative in paragraph
6.6
6.9 kobit 19
impact is a principal driver with an
anticipated rental
income loss of 792 000
income loss in the first quarter has
actually been minimal and primarily void
related
but there are real concerns that some
employed tenants will be impacted
by the ending of the furlough scheme in
october you would hoped it would be a
case
more of rental payments deferred rather
than rental income lost
but obviously the outcome is very
unclear when we submit to close
monitoring over the coming months
this report also covers the hra capital
programme
spending in the first quarter was
minimal as a consequence of kobit 19
a number of projects have fallen behind
schedule
the detail is in appendix a and the
section on capital in the report
starting at paragraph 6 11. the
financial position is for noting only at
this early stage
i'd like to move the recommendations to
that effect as set out in section 3 of
the report
i would like to invite councillor julie
flatman as cabinet member for housing
to second those recommendations thank
you
thank you chair yes i am really happy to
second the proposal um and i'd also
like to say that there's been so much
work done during the covoid
covid and the shutdown that um
you know it's been business as usual or
even more business
and i think our housing team have done a
fantastic job
and we will support those residents who
are finding themselves in difficulty and
it's not
uh we will be working with them
thank you thank you councillor flatman
um
over to your council award for baber
thank you i would like to introduce
report bca 1961 to the cabinet which is
the housing revenue account quarter one
financial monitoring for
this year the report covers the hra
revenue budget and the capital program
and like the general fund report
extrapolates a forecasted outcome for
the full year compared with the budget
based on the data from the first three
months of the financial year
it too incorporates the impact of curbid
19.
in the subject of further budget
variations that arise during the rest of
the financial year
a deficit of 17 000 pounds is forecast
this is an adverse variance of 351 000
pounds compared with
the original budget surplus and all this
is detailed in section
6.3 of the report a detailed breakdown
of the actual variances is shown in
section 6.6 to 6.10 of the report
the principle um contributed to this
is an adverse variance of 882 000 pounds
in income from dwelling rents
and obviously this is forecast as a
result of covered 19
and it's based on a reduction uh of 15
for 26 weeks
and is after taking into account those
tenants receiving housing benefit or
universal credit
however this is an unclear position and
much hopefully will be deferred rather
than lost
offsetting this are underspends
elsewhere within the hra
there's a favorable variance of 175 000
pounds for housing management
182 000 pounds for planned maintenance
and 146 thousand pounds for responsive
repairs and maintenance
as explained in the report there has
been a reduction in spend on whole on
the whole house servicing contract
a focus on urgency urgent and emergency
jobs and also some employee cost savings
i should at this point remind you all
that we still have healthy reserves and
an overall
hra balance of just under 14 million
pounds as described in paragraph
6.10
both councils capital programs have been
reviewed to refine the pipeline of new
build development and acquisitions
alongside the review of the 30-year
business plan
and the affordability of these schemes a
more accurate picture is expected after
quarter two when this work will have
been completed
the capital program is itemized in
appendix a and further detail provided
in paragraph 6 11 to 614 of the report
due to covert 19 a number of projects
have fallen behind schedule and their
budgets will be carried forward to meet
expenditure incurred next year
before opening up for questions in
debate i'd first like to move the
recommendations in section 3 of the
report
that the shortfall of seventeen thousand
pounds be noted and let the capital
program be noted
and may i have a second for these
recommendations please
counselor osborne yeah thank you mr
chairman i am more than happy to second
this report
and like my opposite in mid suffolk i
would like to add my thanks to
the housing team who have done a
fantastic job
before covid but even more so through
covid
and i thank them very much for the work
that they've done
and just to also add that the housing
team
are very much there to support tenants
who are in genuine need
because of co-fed situation thank you mr
chairman
thank you thank you councillor osborne
so
i'm now going to take questions if you
could raise your hand
and then i'll take questions from
cabinet members first
okay so um
given there's no questions counselor
eben
you snuck in there quick thank you thank
you very much chair yes
i thought i was a bit premature putting
my hand up at the previous items
um thank you very much for allowing me
to ask a question
it was just that with regards to
universal
um credit um claimants
i know there's been a significant
increase in that
um in those um people applying for
universal credit and i welcome
council councillor flatman's comments
with regards to supporting um
our tenants that um may be having to
to apply for that or in receipt of that
but i just wondered how
regularly you know given that government
isn't providing any
grants for the housing revenue account
as they are for general fund um i just
wondered how regularly we're reviewing
the um situation particularly
with regards to those increasing numbers
of of claimants
um and therefore the the impact um well
i
would like to see the council do as much
as you can to support them but the
impact on the housing revenue account
thank you very much thank you council
eben i believe gavin you have an answer
thank you
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
eben for that question
um i think in relation to universal
credit yes we're naturally going to see
an increase in response to
covid and sadly those individuals those
residents that
unfortunately find themselves made
redundant or lose their employment
officers do actively work with dwp
department of work and pensions and they
do actively work with
caseworkers dealing with uc claimants um
because naturally we know
and we've seen from from our experience
that um
our rears are more likely to occur uh
where uc is being paid directly to to
the claimants
um beyond uh the council and
and internally we we're currently
developing some dashboards so that we
can monitor
uh at the touch of a button um the the
level of arrears as a result of uc and
those individuals that we need
to to provide additional support to
but at a county-wide level we're
actually working with
county-wide authorities around
developing
of a new group supporting uh those
vulnerable cohorts such as
um you see claiming such as those on
furlough such as those receiving
free school meals so on and so forth and
actually uh that's a group that's being
formulated
as we speak the first meeting i attended
was last week
and that will be a monthly meeting that
includes offices from the department of
work and pensions and so
um what that will do is is look at it uh
through the the lens of suffolk what's
going on in suffolk
and what we can do as suffolk
authorities to support those individuals
that sadly find themselves in that
position thank you very much for that
thank you very much council osborne do
you have a
question
no sorry it was an old hand sorry madam
chairman thank you
no more questions and i'll open the i it
up for debate
um so if you would like to raise your
hand
if you would like to debate
no okay i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair so midsothe
cabinet members the vote is now in
progress if i could ask you to
cast your votes
okay i'm waiting for one vote to come in
perhaps we could do that one verbally
yeah is
is anybody aware that they haven't cast
their boat
because the is anybody having problems
with the vote
okay chair i'm unable to tell
which person hasn't voted which member
hasn't voted
as we are stuck at six out of seven i
believe it would be best if we did a
roll call
okay just thinking just so that we
confirmed because i don't want to
have two people voting twice by accident
so if we uh
go through when i call your name if you
could say fought against or abstain
uh counselor brewster
we lost it councillor brewster
probably could come back to councillor
brewster yep councillor bern
four councillor flatman
four councillor fleming four
councillor gould four
councillor morley four
councillor richardson four
councillor whitehead four
and councillor brewster are you there
yeah i'm here i'm four
[Music]
sorry thank you councillor that's
unanimous chair
thank you very much and if you could now
do the baby vote
okay thank you so
baba members the vote should now be in
progress if you could
cast your votes please
okay we're waiting for one more vote all
received
okay councillor hulk can i ask for for
your vote please
thank you that's unanimous chair that's
seven votes out of seven
four lovely thank you very much indeed
so now we're going to move on to the
call to item 11 quarter one performance
outcome reporting so uh this is a
a presentation and in line with our
corporate plan we've revised and
refreshed our reporting style to reflect
our strategic
priorities and this is the first
publication in
a revised format which we will continue
to approve
upon going forward for subsequent pork
quarters and i'm now going to invite the
baba cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and improvement
to introduce the item thank you
thank you madam chair hopefully we're
all up and running
um so yeah just following on from your
introduction there chair
um so the performance reports being uh
the first of their kind uh as they are
presented to us today cover the period
between
april and june and therefore obviously
include the covert 19 response
activities
as well as our strategic priorities
members you'll see the format for each
service area
is firstly the headline uh followed
um by the objectives and the progress as
measured against our strategic
priorities um previous performance
reports have included operational
measures
uh and those continue to be available on
connect so we can dig down into the
uh into the data um there is a lot of
awful lot of information on here
um uh one of the key areas that um
that i would like to draw members of
attention to is indeed the uh
the areas of activities around the
communities particularly um
and the work that has been undertaken
during the past
uh three months as well um whilst we've
been covering the uh the covid
pandemic uh an extraordinary amount of
work i'm sure everybody will agree
that's taken place
so um hopefully members have had an
opportunity to
digest the reports as they are
and obviously we'll be glad to uh to
take any questions as they arise
thank you very much thank you councillor
parker so i'm now going to invite
um the assistant director for customer
services sarah wilcox who's now going to
talk us through the presentation
thank you sarah thank you chair um
good afternoon councillors thank you
cabinet members for your introduction
to our first iteration of this new style
performance report
and just to clarify really intended to
focus
and reflect on on the council's overall
performance
with respect to quarter one of 2020
the slides are all available in um in
the
papers that you all have access to i'm
not envisioning going through
all of the content in the slides because
there is an awful lot there
and i'm conscious of time but just
wanted the opportunity to run through
some context with yourselves you'll see
that the presentation has a very
different look and feel from previous
years
and is much more focused on reflecting
the performance against our corporate
plan
and is therefore much more focused on
strategic high-level priorities
the presentation has has been grouped
around our six key
strategic priorities so communities
housing well-being customers
environment and the economy and
illustrates for each
of for each council a number of headline
performance indicators
and then three or four key objectives
against each of those priorities
we've also identified a seventh group
that we've categorized as health of the
organization
and the measures and the objectives
within this section
really reflect the work that underpins
and provides the foundation for us as an
effective and efficient organization
and one that then can therefore deliver
against our corporate plan
as councillor parker confirmed the
presentation does reflect a snapshot in
time
and for the most part does cover the
period april may
june 2020 and throughout this period
obviously both councils were very much
focused on responding to the coronavirus
pandemic
and you'll see that this has been
reflected throughout the presentation
so you'll see references to specific
additional work undertaking there's a
direct consequence of the emergency
so for example within the communities
theme we talk and
you can read about the impact of our
home but not alone referrals
and within the housing theme we
reference the everyone in project
with a substantial piece of work
undertaken and still continues around
our homelessness
additionally there are also references
to where we've had to pause
some planned activity so that we could
prioritize
our response to the emergency as i
mentioned this is the first iteration of
a completely different style performance
report
all of the old measures that we use to
focus on a much more operational level
are still available
for all members and officers to view and
moving into the second quarter
and beyond we fully expect that this
style will continue to evolve
we expect to make a number of tweaks and
improvements moving forwards
we want the presentation to serve both
as an update and a snapshot in time
of our council's overall performance as
well as look forward
to all of the exciting new pieces of
work and projects that will be coming up
and so this is very much seen as a piece
of continuous improvement
that we will look to evolve over the
next few quarters
so with that in mind i'll hand you back
to the chair for
any comments thank you thank you
thank you very much um so
we're now going to take questions so if
anybody would like to ask a question
please raise your hand now
councillor arthi
yeah thanks i'm not sure whether you
were inviting questions from cabinet
members or from
other members taking part everybody
everybody okay
um well i've got a question about um
really it's um being unclear
about some of the statistics in
this report um and whether they apply to
both councils
or one council
sometimes it says baba only or mid-south
africa only sometimes there are just
figures
now obviously to do with staffing and
stuff i would imagine that's obviously
shared staff so it's it's the same
figure
but it seems to me that there are a few
cases where we're not sure whether the
figures
the pounds figures or the statistics are
um one council or shared
and on page 26 i notice
that baba district council was named as
one of the uk's top councils
presumably mid-suffolk were not
was that a question i'm sorry chairman i
thought that was a question yes
um it was a question about
how the figures um are arrived at
and when they are joint and when they
are one council only
thank you thank you thank you councillor
arthi uh yeah we do
try to um make reference to
where if the figures are just specific
to one authority
but gen gen generally um they would
cover
uh both sometimes it's not possible for
us to to split those out
over the individual authorities
depending on the
on the individual statistic but i'm
happy to take that away
and um to make sure that that's clearer
for for further
uh reports moving forwards
okay and just to be clear on page 26
baba being named as one of the uk's top
10 councils that was
just baber not weber and mid-suffolk
um if uh if it's on there as baba
district then
then yes it would be as baba district
council
i think this probably relates to a
specific campaign that we ran on social
media
where it was picked up um and so it is
uh
would likely to be baber related
and i'm happy to go away and clarify
that for you yes it was a social media
one thank you
okay any other cabinet members got any
questions before i move on to
everybody else
no thank you clive if you could put your
hand down
thank you cancer eben
thank you very much chair um i had a
same question as councillor arthur lee
about
it not being clear which whether the
numbers quoted were related to both
councils or um
or or just one or the single counts of
which the report is
is being done and um the fact that the
officer said
um and i quote they generally cover both
has confused
the matter even more but um anyway i'll
leave that one at that
if that could be made clear in the
future i think that'd be really helpful
but my other question is that about
comparisons
um i think only on the um customers
um data are there comparisons
so for example under the well-being data
it refers to seven active schools um
so is that in is that in relation to 10
previously or two previously
because if it so whether it's an
increase or a decrease for example
you know similarly on housing you know
36 properties relay is this is that
better or worse than than previously and
i wondered if that
um could be um addressed and i also note
that there's
some fairly key indicators i would have
thought such as in housing
um we there aren't numbers on
say a number of homes purchased or um
right to buy um houses
sold and i appreciate obviously this
most recent quarter is
completely um covered related so it
might be that you're
intending to put those figs in future
reports um
but i just wondered um you know
where some of those that key data would
be thank you very much chair
thank you sarah thank you chair
yes counselor ebon just to to reassure
you um
i think what we were trying to do with
the new style format was
to highlight the strategic
priorities particularly and and the
links with the with the corporate
plan there are a vast range of
um of statistics and performance
measures
that all of our service teams across the
two
districts continue to collate and report
upon
it's just that we haven't put them all
in all in this um
in this presentation we were concerned
about the presentation
being able to to be viewed in a in a way
that
you know didn't require hours and hours
and swathes of information on on excel
spreadsheets which
which was the case beforehand but i'm
happy to reassure you that the
information continues to be collected
and is available
on connect and so some of those
particular operational measures that
you've mentioned with respect to housing
are there we do continue to
monitor and benchmark where appropriate
as well and that information
is contained on those reports within
the internet on connect as well where we
think it's relevant or adds value then
we
we will illustrate that further in
ongoing iterations of this presentation
and but i'm sure as you appreciate
benchmarking can be quite difficult
when trying to measure like for like
because um it's not always given that
we are measuring apples with apples um
if you like so
we do hold that information moving
forward and and
our intention is to continue to do so
we're just elevating certain information
into a slightly different format
to give a clearer view of progress
against strategic priorities
thanks thanks very much for that but i
do think that some key
data such as you know the amount of
homes we're purchasing for example
should be on a report like this it's
public rather than
connect which is the um council's
internal
um internet but um hopefully i can i'll
discuss that with you um at a later date
thank you very much chair
thank you councillor mccraw
uh there we are i managed to get that
done in time i do apologize
um actually i'd like to follow on from
councillor ebern's point there because i
think it's a valid one
i must say though i do love and i think
this is a really nice
piece of presentation the use of color
it's effective
and it will explain things perhaps
rather better
than the very lengthy tables but that
being said i looked forward to those
very lengthy tables every quarter
because
and particularly the third and fourth
quarters the first quarter is
less concerning although of course with
kobig 19 that's perhaps not the case
what i would like to suggest perhaps and
i wanted to ask officers if this will be
possible is that
either the information that was
previously published in the format it
was published and will be
on connect could either be available as
an
as an appendix or and i know that means
that people will go into great depth and
detail but that's actually what
counselor ebern is suggesting and i
would concur with
or a link be provided but given that
that link would be to connect
and that's not accessible to the general
public perhaps that wouldn't be the case
could uh have any comments from officers
on on whether that would be possible
because i don't want us to lose as
counselor even suggests
some useful data and just go for if you
don't mind my saying
headline information great graphics
lovely use of color
it's not quite the whole story though
we're not losing any data no we're not
losing data
it's whether it's actually um openly
accessible to the general public as well
as to ourselves
and i think that's an important point
and a cacao ebon is correct to raise it
so i'm just suggesting either a link or
an appendix
sarah thank you chair and thank you
councillor mcgraw yes our aspiration is
absolutely to
be in a position where we are very
transparent with our with our data and
all of our performance information and
that we surface that
uh to members of the public as well as
to yourselves
currently the situation um is such that
we are that's what we're working on
and we're not in a position at the
moment to um
to provide it in a way that we feel is
is uh
user-friendly for residents to be able
to access that information
but happy to explore um in the meantime
looking at providing a link um
if that was helpful thank you thank you
councillor field
yes i i think those two points were
valuable
a link would be useful i did want to
make just
um another couple of points uh
just restricted to one area i'm looking
at page 61 of your report
it says for instance we plan what we
plan to do next
that's good um business case for
transferring
leisure etaris from blue to green okay
um develop an electric electronic
vehicle charging business case
um neither of these have got any sort of
target
dates or anything or you know there
could be any time in the next
several years um and
that's probably true the two points
above that as well although beginning
picking
intention is pretty clear but just
making the point that i i think
sometimes one wants to keep these things
clear and
and concise but some idea
of when we're intending to do this would
be really useful
and that sort of reveal reflects back
through throughout the document here
if you're going to state that we're
going to do something we should want to
we really should know what the time
frame is
thank you councillor field sarah thank
you councilman marlin
councillor field yes i agree with your
with your point
and that's something that we will be
looking at um
to improve upon in further iterations of
this report
as a rule of thumb the guidance we've
given when
um discussing this with other colleagues
across the organization is that
what we plan to do next is usually
typically what would be coming in the
next quarter
but i take your point and we'll be
looking at making sure that that's much
clearer
in future iterations thank you
thank you uh councillor wellam thank you
chad
um just a couple of queries one is on
page 55 um
we've got some comparisons there for
instance complements received
70s and increase of 126 percent so
underneath we've got complaints received
we've got the number but we don't know
whether it's an increase or a decrease
so as other councillors have said that
would be very useful
um and also i wonder if um a
significant number of the complaints
seem to be about contractor improvement
that that could be a concern of a
contractor in one district
who's not operating in the other so
those probably need to be broken down if
that is the case
and the other the other query is on page
on page 60
it's to do with mileage
um if i can find it
um this reduction in staff miles
traveled
um
that's a reduction of 120 000 miles
which seems quite a lot
um but we've got is it partly to do with
code
although much of that was before the
kovid period
um but we don't know what to compare it
with
is that is that sorry counselor what
page are you looking at
page 60 page 60 thank you
who would like to answer that sarah
could i just check this quickly yes
sorry i was gonna say because the
reports are slightly different so that
that figure actually on the baby report
was actually shown on page 62
um or page 18 of the actual report just
uh just to clarify
thank you chair and i'm happy to to
reply to the latter point about the mile
edge
okay thank you yeah um so so i'm looking
at page
60 on that relevant report but it's the
same figure on both so
i'm hoping that that's actually
straightforward and does answer all of
councillor willem's
questions but but it clearly it doesn't
because that's not the way that
councilwoman has read it so
that is a reduction in staff miles
traveled of 120 000 miles
that's the figure for both districts so
the bid in italics belief
is just confirming that that figure is
for both districts combined
and that's comparing the january to
march period
with the current quarter that we're
talking about so that's talking about
120 000 miles
less than were traveled between january
and march
2020 which is the other bit in italics
and you're absolutely right it's
entirely to do with covid
right thank you but we don't know
whether that's
um i mean it could it could well be a a
huge reduction but we don't know
i it certainly is a huge reduction in
terms of that being 120 000 but i take
the point
you haven't got a the actual figure from
the previous quarter no
um and most of what's in here is is um
is good news i just hope that if there
are problem areas that need highlighting
that they would be highlight
highlighted in the same sort of way yeah
absolutely and just sticking with that
same page um
and directly above the 120 000 so the
fact that we had to suspend
the the garden waste service for eight
weeks clearly that's not good news
uh and but you're absolutely right that
the intention on this report and future
versions of it
as sarah was saying is to be able to
highlight uh both positive and negative
in that regard so there is a
full report the key thing being and just
if i can just take a moment
just picking up the various points that
were made about data data of course is
important
what we want here more is analysis so
what does this tell you
about the performance of the council
against the corporate plan
uh as both cabinet members and the
leader
set out at the start not so much what
does it tell you about the performance
of an individual service
in minute detail that of course is of
relevance to officers it's of interest
to members i'm sure but we don't want to
try and go back to what we had before
and i'm
pleased to hear the support from from
several members not to go back to the
rest and roster data rather than
analysis
absolutely thank you thank you
councillor fleming
thank you yeah i would also um
just wanted to comment on are you asking
me a question
no i wanted to i was responding to the
mileage question
but i'm making a comment okay is that
all right
that's fine yeah because i think um
a value like 120 000 miles less than
last year
um isn't really meaningful unless we
know what the total number of miles
traveled was
um we might be several million in which
case 125
000 is is very little so i i do think
yeah i know we're trying to get away
from a lot of statistics and boring
numbers
but i think there are some numbers that
we will need to provide in order to make
the numbers we show meaningful
to people so you know what i'm saying is
i think you know we just need to
play with this format a little bit more
so that it's clear to the public
you know what our improvements or
otherwise
really mean okay thank you
uh counselor willem you've still got
your hand up
counselor field
yes and i meant it this time um
just is it a comment is it a question
looking again at
incidents of fly tipping um great that
95
were cleared and useful information i
think residents will be pretty
interested to know
how many people we um
prosecuted or nailed to the wall for
their endeavors
um so just another figure that could
i realize i'm not adding to the number
of numbers but something that would
certainly interest people in my area
okay noted
so counselor fleming would you like to
put your hand down
thank you okay so the i this item is
noted
um this is only for noting so
we're not going to have a debate and no
vote is required for this one
uh council ward did you want to ask a
question
uh yeah actually yes i should have put
my hand up a bit earlier um
i just uh a couple of things um and it's
on the health of the
organization um it's good to see this
this indicator uh coming in now and um
i think we can be
reassured by some of the data that's
coming out in in that um
not just um obviously with the the fact
that we are making an impression on on
social media and it's good to see that
babe is one of the
uh top 10 councils that that um
really goes uh hand in hand with the
fact that in the halifax quality of life
survey we were voted eighth best
council so um uh i think we must be
doing something right
um uh notwithstanding our detractors out
there in the community
um but uh in terms of the healthy
organization 95
of the staff felt uh fairly well
informed about the current situation
and and we've got uh average number of
sick days
um per fde are way down but um
we do need to keep an eye on things i
think that there's been quite a bit on
uh the president on uh tv and radio
recently about
um uh particularly amongst the the
younger members of staff
that a number of organizations are
finding are
struggling coping with working from home
and
and do benefit
from the social interaction of coming
into the office from time to time so i
think we do need to
to start looking at that and making sure
that um
that's not having an adverse impact and
and perhaps we do need to
to bring them back once in a while so
that they they can get that
benefit of of um networking um
amongst their peers but um i i think
generally though we've we've done pretty
well in terms of uh keeping things going
and um
and and coping with the kerbin crisis so
i'm
i'm i'm pleased with the way this
indicator is going
thanks thank you counselor arthi have
you got a question
um it's not really a question it's a
comment as a result of the
the question about the staff miles when
i first
saw this figure a few months ago
i was quite surprised and i worked out
exactly how far
120 000 miles would get you
and the answer is that it would be
nearly five times around the
circumference of the earth
or halfway to the moon and that's just
in three months
the only thing this figure doesn't say
though is whether those
were business miles or miles to work and
back again
so it would be quite interesting to know
what the saving was
in terms of what we pay in mileage as a
result
of that reduction in mileage
sarah arthur anybody
yeah i'll come in first and hopefully
somebody else will be able to save me in
terms of the actual figure so
these are all business miles so that's
why we know them that's why we know the
figure
um so these are miles that would have
otherwise been claimed um so if you
think about it was 120
000 miles that was claimed in the
previous three months and so there will
be a direct saving
i can't remember off top of my head with
it's 45 pm mile of 50p a mile of 40 a
mile but somebody i'm hoping
will be able to save me in that regard
um but you can quickly work out the
roughly speaking
the amount of money that were that would
be involved as a result
i i have it's 50 000 pounds um
but um i presume there are also other
benefits
in the the mileage that staff travel to
work and back home again afterwards
they're not included here because
they're not business miles
um so the actual reduction in miles is
probably more than 120
000 absolutely right and in addition to
that obviously it's not just a financial
saving but there will be a carbon
impact or lack of impact as a result as
well
can i just ask does that include
counsellor miles
i don't know sarah do you know whether
that figure included the council of
mileage
um i don't know but happy to go away and
clarify that
just an interesting thought
okay thank you councillor whitehead yes
just a quick question on the customers
with customers telephoning us the data's
showing that
it's taking 35 35 seconds which is an
average wait time down 64
from last quarter now i do assume that
the
people being contacted or answering the
phone presumably working from home and
therefore
i'm surprised it's come down so much is
it actually telling us that when people
are working from home they're actually
answering the phone quicker than they
were before um
that's my question thank you sarah
um what i can say is that we've been
very effective
ourselves working from from home um
and that the technology has allowed us
to do that with a new telephony system
uh that was uh put in place at the
beginning of the
year obviously our wait times do are
impacted upon by volumes of people
trying to to call us as well um and
whilst we
see fluctuations all throughout the year
um
we we have seen um less less volume
coming through
which will have an impact on our on our
times
but happy to report that yes we have a
an average wait time of uh
just 35 seconds okay thank you because
most organizations iphone join cove
have been really slow to respond and
have a message sort of saying
you know there's fewer staff around and
please wait for a while to be
you know your 20-minute queue and things
like that so i think that's good
for us yeah fantastic achievement
uh clive have you got another question
no i'm so sorry i failed to take my hand
down
thank you um cassandra
hello chair thank you i just wanted to
confirm that these staff miles do also
include member miles as well so any
miles
came by members too lovely thank you
very much indeed
the councillor wellam yeah just a very
quick question
um during covid we've been given
we've given mobile numbers for
contacting staff anyway but
i think we've been more likely to
contact um
staff by uh by mobile
during covid and i just wondered whether
they the average wait time takes account
of
mo of mobile telephone calls as well as
the calls to
the uh one double four nine number or a
one four seven three number
i'm not sure how our system could tell
that but yeah
thank you councillor yes this is just in
respect of our
um our main number and doesn't include
individual mobile numbers that we would
give out
thank you so no more questions
this item is just for noting so
thank you all for the the questions that
was
really good so we're now moving on to
item
12 mca 19
71 and bca 19
62 which are the sill expenditure
programs for september 2020
for mids afghan for baba respectively so
i'll now invite the mid suffolk cabinet
member for planning to introduce
the mid-suffolk district council report
councillor bern
yes thank you chairman
this is a report on the community
infrastructure levy
expenditure program
which contains an update on the progress
on decisions in bid rounds one two three
and four
also included is a list of emerging
project
for silbids in appendix a
section c and this latter is another
change made as a result of the recent
sil
expenditure framework review i'm sorry
about all these different
types of sill documents which you have
to contend with but it's a complex
it's a complex issue and
complex methods are used to
monitor and determine everything
um from the cabinet you'll see that
there are six bids for which
their our recommendations
uh five of which for cabinet to make and
uh one for cabinet to note
and i'll just whip through which is a
euphemism for taking quite a long time
um whip through the various date
the various bids um the six bids i'm
talking about
i'll do them as quickly as i can um bed
m20
is a thurston railway the thirst and
rail station
uh and this is um this is
money that will be coming from ring
fence infrastructure
from the first and only and the bid is a
hundred thousand pounds which includes
ten thousand pound throat safety audits
um the scope of the rail feasibility
study has been agreed with the project
group for this bid
and aims to address recent housing
growth in the village
by improvements of the station which
will also be the subject of
consideration by highways
the project is essential in the
infrastructure delivery plan and a
project group
exists which includes rail
representatives highway representatives
the parish council and district and
county members together with
southern county council and mid-southern
district council
officers to steer this project forwards
in line with the stoke sill expenditure
framework requirements
time scales for the feasibility work
would start september 2020 and conclude
march 2021 if this so bid were to be
supported
this is important infrastructure and the
completion of the feasibility study is a
necessary part
of the rail process this is known as
grip which is the
governance of railway infrastructure
projects
a protocol which um network
rail or the rail system as a whole
insists is followed on any piece of rail
work that isn't straightforward
maintenance
the next bit is a stone market bid a
regal car park
m21 iphone 18.
and this is again ring first ring fenced
infrastructure
fun stone market only and
is a bid for um 10
263 pounds uh total costs for this
scheme
are 12 940.
um it defects the district council's car
park where there is a significant
investment
and change occurring because of the
improvements to the regal theatre
the project aims to support this and
encourages charging opportunities
for electric cars within the market town
the stone market
the proposed installation of two fast
charge ev
charging points would mirror existing
installations at needham markets
which are rapidly ev charger points and
i which are two ev fast charger points
and help provide a network of charging
opportunities
it represents an oven ready affordable
scheme that meets the council's
respect to sustainable transport aims
and objectives
um next a bid in i which
is bit m19 hyphen 2012
uh which is a moore's children's play
area
again from the local or this one from
the local infrastructure fund
a sale bid of 31 605
pounds uh for a total cost
uh of the project of 62 858.
this proposal of replacing outdated and
unsafe play equipment is well supported
by the community
including the children of i who have
been consulted on the type of equipment
they would like to have
the project will provide much improved
leisure and community facilities for the
community
and encourages active outdoor play for
the children
revised scoping of the project together
with amended costings
and the screening for unspent one of six
contributions
has reduced the level of sill being
asked for in this respect
uh of the uh from in respect to this
project i'm sorry
uh from fifty thousand pounds which it
was originally
to thirty one thousand six hundred and
five
now this equates to fifty percent of the
total cost of the works of
as i've said and meets the new
requirements of the sill expenditure
framework
the fourth bid is for debenham uh bedm
1903
which is the leisure center for an
additional car park
uh from the local infrastructure fund
it's a still bid for 47
000 pounds uh for a project costing
in total uh 89
080 90 000.
the purpose of the project is to provide
additional parking 41 spaces for the
community
not just for leisure center unit users
many different users use the current car
parking facility
such as the staff and visitors of the
debenham high school
during term time the parents of the
debenham high school pupils for
parents evenings and other events
visitors to neighboring groups including
the youth group
mother and baby etc and residents
disposing of recyclable materials
the creation of this additional car park
would therefore benefit the new
and future residents as well as the
wider community
the debenham neighborhood plan made in
march 28
2019 also makes references to the
leisure center and its importance in
providing car parking
planning permission has been granted for
the car park and revised costings
together with the screening for unspent
one of six contributions
has reduced the level of sill being
asked for
from 90 000 to 47
000. this equates to the sill bid being
52 the total cost of the works and meets
the new requirements of the sil
expenditure framework uh
and finally for a decision today
uh the wingfield barnes bed
uh m 20 uh hyphen 08
which is the conversion of a granary uh
as a children's nursery again from the
local infrastructure fund
a sale bid of 34 000 pounds
of total costs of the project um
59 and a half thousand pounds
now this property is owned by the
district council planning permissions
being granted for the proposed use of
the granary
for children's nursery together with
listed building consent for the pro
proposed alterations the project is to
be funded
collaboratively collaboratively with
funds from the wingfield bound cic
of ten thousand pounds and a med suffolk
district council community grant
of uh fifteen and a half thousand
the level of still being asked for in
respect to this project it's 34 000
which equates to
uh 57 percent of the total cost of works
and meets the new uh requirements of the
civil expenditure framework and then
finally there's one decision for cabinet
to note
which is bedfield bid m19
iphone 13 which a new play area from the
local infrastructure fund
still bid 40 uh four and a half thousand
pounds
total costs 35 000 pounds
and this proposal represents a scheme
with wide community support
that would provide additional leisure
and community facilities for the
community
and encourage outdoor active play for
the children
um the project is to be funded
collaboratively from a variety of
organizations
including the national lottery midsole
district council community grant
ten thousand each from those two as well
as other organizations
and the local business adnans we're also
contributing
the proportion of the funds so this
equates to the sill bit being
only 30 percent of 13 of the total cost
of the works
and meets the new requirements of the
sill expenditure framework
the project has been determined under
delegated powers and is the covenant to
note only
works have already started on site with
partial partial drawdown of
funds to pay for completed works so the
recommendations
are set out in your report a paragraph
3.1
cabinet to make these decisions at
thurston
stone market i debenham and wingfield
and to note the delegated decision at
bedfield
and then at paragraph 3.2 you're asked
to note and endorse
the sill expenditure program thank you
thank you councillor do we have a second
well until we do um could i just say
that
you will you will appreciate from all
that i've
just been saying that uh the the
business of um
uh of assessing these bids receiving
these bids
checking them through uh deciding
whether
the projects can be supported by other
grants that are available
from other sources etc etc is a huge
amount of work which is done by
a very small team and so um
i would like to complement
christine thurlow and her team for
excellent work on this um on this
particular field
thank you thank you councillor bern do i
have a seconder
okay second
i'm very happy to second this madam
chair sorry i was uh on the wrong path
wrong screen when i was trying to be uh
dude
okay thank you thank you thank you
councillor fleming um
before i move on and ask
councillor ward to introduce the
baber sill report um can i just ask a
question of the
of our monitoring officer uh i
am a lifetime member of debenhams sports
and lev leisure
do i need to declare a non-pecuniary
interest
in the debenhams hill bid yes you can do
okay thank you um council award would
you like to
start off yes thank you um
and uh at this point i'd like to invite
the baby cabinet member for planning
to introduce the the baby's seal report
so if i'll hand over to councillor
arthur now please
thanks john um yes our report
is um is not um quite so lengthy as the
mid-suffolk one um and that's simply
because
although you've got a lot of detail in
your papers um
the recommendations are actually very
very simple and for noting only
and that's because there are no bids
for you to approve today as i said
they're just two for noting
um so the bundle of papers that you've
got
um that all of the the preamble is
similar to the mid-suffolk stuff so
you've got the
the cabinet report the the sill
expenditure program
um and the technical assessments for the
individual seal bids
that's an appendix b um
you've also got updates um on decisions
that have been made
in all of the previous bid rounds
for you today for noting are just two
projects
um there's the the first one is in
hadley um
and that's at the the health center and
that's for
conversion of a room um for chemotherapy
treatment
um the amount being sought there is is
relatively low
that's um 3526 pounds
um which obviously comes under the
delegated decision limit of 10 000
pounds
so that's why it's only for noting and
that work is now complete
the second one is for holbrook village
hall
and that's an enhancement an upgrade of
the existing facilities
in the kitchen um that's
something that didn't need planning
permission
um and the amount being sought there is
9
900 pounds um that represents i think
about 70
just under 75 of the total cost
of the work if you remember um we have
put a 75 000
sorry a 75 000 and a 75
limit on on funding now um and that
decision
um was taken in august so as i said
that's
just for noting you will see within the
the papers the progress on the the
previous bids
and i will remind you that in june um
there were three bids for your approval
they were in sudbury chelsworth and
newton
um and that the amount that you approved
then totaled just under three hundred
thousand pounds
but all you have to do today is um
approval of the recommendations at 3.1
and 3.2
which has as i said are for noting if
anybody has any detailed questions on
any of the other bids
um i'm pleased that we've got christine
thurlow with us um
and hopefully she'll be able to to
answer those
thank you
and do you have a secondary
yes style second okay thank you council
award
so if everybody you could put your hands
up if you wish to
ask a question
brewster
you're muted counselor brewster
i did wonder about this but i i having
said
having you said did you should you have
declared an interest in the debenham one
um yeah i think i should probably
declare a non-pecuniary interest in
in the stone market one as well okay
thank you
if there's no more questions from
cabinet members
i'll go to councillor wellam
thank you chair and just a quick query
on page 92 one of the appendices where
we have two sto upland developments
listed there
um the first development is for 75 homes
the second is for 100 homes
there was a third application which was
approved
which was for i think it was for 34 of
the homes
approved under the second of those
applications
to be replaced by 53 homes bringing the
total
up to 194 so i wonder if that
that would presumably make a difference
to the amount of sill to be collected
i'm not expecting an answer now it's
just something that perhaps could be
looked into
thank you uh christine do you
do i happen to know offhand uh no i
don't i
off hand but i'm happy to take that
offline and
find out and let councillor well i'm now
okay thank you very much
any more questions
okay so we're going to move into debate
if you'd like to raise your hands
if you would like to debate
no okay i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you sorry check can i just make
a point since there's only since there's
only eight of us isn't it quicker to do
a roll call rather than battle around
with this electronic stuff i can
understand it for the council when
there's
40 or whatever there is but for eight
people it's quicker to just read our
names out isn't it
it's not about speed it's about getting
you used to using the system
we'll continue with the electronic vote
okay how are the other 25 members going
to get used to the system
then they will have their own routine
okay thank you chair
the mid-suffolk vote is now in progress
so if i can ask you to
cast your votes now please
okay thank you uh chair may i ask your
vote please
four thank you so that is
unanimous chair emotions carried thank
you very much
thank you and for
labour members if you could cast your
votes now please
okay councillor hulk can i ask for your
vote please
yes you can i'm four
so thank you okay again that's unanimous
thank you emotions carried
thank you very much so that concludes
the
business of the day the date and time of
the next meeting
is scheduled for monday the 28th of
september at
0 9 30. thank you everybody for taking
part
see you again soon thank you
you